[Applause]
oh my God I'm so I believe Megan thank
you so much for coming here I sat up all
night and then had the wildest dreams it
really affected like my REM cycle my
aura ring was like whoa what happened
last night to you and it's because I
read every single page of your book and
I just sat there
for oh a couple of hours just really
taking it in can I read you the poem
that made me have to put the book down
on my chest and think for a while yeah I
would love that okay did you read a book
did you read it you know what he he was
on the
bed I will always be in love with the
man that you'll never
become and the poem is called unrealized
potential can I ask for you what this is
about I think that could be applied to
many people throughout my life but I
think when you're in a relationship with
somebody who you see so much potential
in them and so much you connect to their
soul and you know who they could be or
who they should be um and because of
their own childhood traumas and unhealed
issues they're not able to be who
they're meant to be or who they can be
and they operate at a lower frequency
than where they should be and they are
they wear a a mask of some of someone
that's not really who you know that they
they can be to you and you know that
they could treat you better and that the
love could be so much stronger and could
be special and this relationship could
be so much more but because they're not
willing to get the help they'll never be
their best self and so you can stay and
forever be in love with who they could
possibly become one day or or you know
you could move on and it's a it's a
gamble because you don't want to waste
your life and your time waiting for
somebody to grow into themselves because
that may never happen but I feel like a
lot of us do that we're in love with the
potential not the
reality
okay that was such a healing answer
because I think why it affected me so
much is I'm still stuck you know I'm
still closed for
[Music]
business